Abraham chimagotti is making sure his
plow is ready for the field
he hopes to start planting soon as long
as there isn't another drought this year
last season he and his wife Emma grew
sorghum Millet sunflowers and Maize but
they maize crop Zimbabwe staple food
didn't do well we are facing challenges
of climate and also we are receiving
very little rainfall and the the pattern
is ran for distribution is very poor
here in mudzi so for maize to
Crowell we are facing challenges it's
one reason why the government wants more
Farmers to grow traditional crops such
as Millet and sorghum the country
experiences a lean season every year
from October to March is the driest
period before rain starts when families
have few to no food stocks as Government
we came up with a program where we say
is the region where the farmer is found
that determines the type of crop that
the farmer should and must grow in this
dry and arid regions small grains or
what we would term traditional grains
are the most adaptable type of crop that
are suitable for these environments many
farmers are growing traditional grains
but on a small scale Maize is more
popular here and an important cash crop
Abraham's family says at first they
weren't sure about growing a lot of
sorghum but it paid off
the family sold most of what was
harvested and this is what's left in
storage 13 bags of sorghum it's enough
to keep them going for a few months
until the next Harvest
humanitarian agencies and the government
plan to feed more than 3 million people
during this lean season getting more
people to grow traditional grains could
take some time but low yields recurring
droughts and food shortages are
encouraging more families to embrace
drought resistant crops and as they
require less fertilizer and are more
nutritious more than I believe it could
be the way to go haramutasa Al Jazeera
Zimbabwe